dans ces images de l'armée afghane on
voit des militaires défendre une ville
du nord en tirant au lance-roquettes
l'avancée des talibans un spectaculaire
depuis le début du retrait des forces
américaines qui sera terminé avant la
date prévue du 11 septembre
l'échéance symbolique exactement vingt
ans après l'attaqué contre les tours du
world trade center à new york qui avait
incité george bush a déployé des troupes
en afghanistan en octobre 2001 les
américains bombardent les talibans qui
refusent de livrer le leader d'al-quaida
caché en afghanistan irresponsable des
attaques du 11 septembre les forces
américaines et celles de l'otan repousse
les islamistes qui perdent le pouvoir
les écoles sont rouvertes les femmes
peuvent de nouveau être scolarisés et
travailler mes 20 ans plus tard si c'est
qu'ils sont menacés
depuis trois mois les talibans
reprennent un à un les territoires
perdus y compris kandahar où les
canadiens étaient basés depuis une
semaine la ville qui a vu naître les
talibans est de nouveau au coeur des
combats ici un bataillon des forces
spéciales temps d'éviter les tirs
ennemis les talibans qui contrôlent déjà
une bonne partie de la province de
kandahar affirme être sur le point de
reprendre aussi les vignes faut disent
les militaires
morales l'ennemi dit le major n'a pas
les moyens de combattre les forces
spéciales afghanes
s'ils disent avoir gagné un territoire
c'est juste de la propagande
une chose est certaine les combats sont
intenses depuis deux jours l'hôpital de
kandahar a reçu des centaines de blessés
trente civils et 15 insurgés sont
décédés ici
il avait
à la nôtre renier
même scénario dans la province de
koundouz où les taliban occulter
l'histoire sauf la capitale encore
défendu par les forces afghanes
douze mille familles ont fui leurs
villages pour se réfugier dans la ville
de koundouz sous des tentes de fortune
après quelques jeux
les lots sur la quatrième de rang
beaucoup d'intellectuels afghan dénonce
ce retrait précipité des forces
américaines qui devait se faire
seulement quand un partage du pouvoir
serait négocié entre toutes les parties
au conflit
et si sophie langlois radio-canada moral